Now, I'd like to introduce our featured presenters today,
Dr. Louis Halamek and Dr. Nicole Yamada.
Dr. Halamek is a Professor in the Division of
Neonatal and Developmental Medicine in the Department of Pediatrics at
Stanford Medicine and he's a Director of
Neonatal Resuscitation at Packard Children's Hospital.
Dr. Halamek is the Founding Director of the Center for Advanced Pediatric and Perinatal
Education and the world's first center dedicated to fetal,
neonatal, pediatric and obstetrics simulation-based training and research.
He is a former member of the Board of Directors of
the International Pediatric Simulation Society,
the Inaugural Board of Directors of the Society for Simulation in Health Care,
and the Inaugural Editorial Board of Simulation in Health Care.
His career in simulation-based training and research began in 1995,
and over the past two decades,
he's refined a method of debriefing based on
his collaboration with colleagues in aerospace,
aviation, and the military.
This objective professional approach to debriefing has been adopted as
a standard for the neonatal resuscitation program of the American Academy of Pediatrics,
it's 25,000 instructors, and 3.3 million trainees.
Dr Yamada is a Clinical Assistant Professor in the Division of
Neonatal and Developmental Medicine in the Department of Pediatrics at Stanford Medicine,
and is an attending neonatologist in
the Intensive Care Unit at Packard Children's Hospital.
Dr. Yamada is the associate director of
the Center for Advanced pediatric and perinatal education.
She is an expert in debriefing teams of healthcare professionals from
all areas of clinical care and of all levels of experience,
and she's worked with teams from
both academic and private hospitals
all over the US as well as teams from around the world.
And she's been invited to deliver
simulation instructor programs in Moscow and Hong Kong.
And with that, let's turn it over to Dr. Halamek and Dr. Yamada.
Thank you Jackie for those kind introductions.
I'd like to emphasize the fact that both
Dr. Yamada and I are practicing neonatologists,
so we look at the debriefing from the vantage point of
healthcare professionals who are leading
teams of people in the care of critically ill patients.
Um, I do want to acknowledge that
our training and debriefing strategies as you mentioned have been
heavily influenced by colleagues in other industries who are outside of healthcare.
And were- in those industries the expectations for both human performance are high,
as well as the risk to human life is high.
And especially like to say thanks to people that we've known over the years,
both at NASA and the FAA for whom- from whom we've learned so much.
Um, I'd also like to point out that while our discussion today is
really focused on health care debriefing, um,
the strategies that we're going to highlight over the course of
the next 40 minutes or so can be applied when debriefing any type of situation.
And that's going to be especially important for our audience, uh,
today because we directly saw that
approximately half of you are actually working in industries outside of healthcare.
Okay. So let's get started the learning objectives as many of you are
aware from when you signed up for the webinar are these listed here.
Um, and they're really specifically related to our selection
of wanting to discuss the really foundational strategies that we think are,
uh, instrumental to funding and effective debriefing.
The outline for our webinars.
First, we'll just start with what is debriefing,
a brief definition there so that we're all on the same page about,
um, what we're talking about today.
And then we'll first cover some guiding principles about how
we generally think about debriefings and our approach to debriefings,
um, in any situation.
And then finally we'll roll into a discussion of
four specific key strategies with video examples of,
um, things that we specifically implement through,
um, all of our debriefings.
I think it's worth mentioning that these are
only just four strategies out of a total of 20,
and we cover all 20 in our online debriefing program,
which you'll hear about later at the end of this webinar.
But these aren't all of the- the solutions to running an effective debriefing,
we just wanted to cover what we think is really
instrumental and foundational during this discussion.
So the first question I think is worth answering is what is a debriefing?
And so for those of you who may not be familiar with what debriefings are,
we really wanted to make sure that we're all on
the same page about what we're discussing here today.
So debriefing at a very basic level is
an interactive discussion of a prior series of events
and can be facilitated in a number of different ways
into different levels of involvement from the debriefer.
And oftentimes that depends on the experience level of those people being debriefed.
So people who may have a lot of experience, um,
with debriefings may be able to even start to
conduct their own self debriefings as a- as a team,
whereas other people who may be less familiar with the,
uh, role and the,
um function of a debriefing may need a little bit more facilitation
from a trained debriefer or someone with experience with debriefing.
The next question is what is a good debriefing?
So now we know what a debriefing is,
but how do you make it- how do you make a good debriefing?
A good debriefing is one that is constructive,
concise, and identifies both strengths and weaknesses.
And oftentimes especially those of us coming from
an environment where we're treating other people or we're educators,
we often focus on what people need to learn,
what they might need to improve on.
And one of the things that we really want to emphasize is that
the- a good debriefing is an opportunity to talk about
both strengths and weaknesses and helping those
that are being debriefed understand what facilitated
their ability to perform really well if they had
a really strong performance and how to replicate that performance again in the future,
mm, and also then taking opportunity to address weaknesses.
Uh, and not only identifying them,
but coming up with strategies to help those people who are being debriefed, um,
learn how to avoid those same challenges or the same weaknesses again in the future.
So I'll let Lou talk about some of the guiding principles that we have for debriefing.
So we'll go ahead and review those now.
The first guiding principle is that instructors
should always maintain a professional business-like,
matter-of-fact tone whether trainee performance was exemplary or highly flawed.
Uh, our overall goal is to enable
the people being debriefed to eventually be able to be brief themselves.
Uh, we want them to be able to do this
without the need for a trained debriefer, certainly in health care.
It's not always going to be possible if we're debriefing
real-life situations to have a trained debriefer present,
and so we want to allow them opportunity to practice this and we want
to draw as much information from them and self critique as we can,
uh, during that debriefing.
Uh, that ability to assess their own performance becomes extremely important,
especially when we were working in the real environment.
Second guiding principle, the role of the instructor in a briefing is to
facilitate rather than dominate discussion among trainees.
Uh, when I lead a debriefing,
my expectation that those being debriefed will
actually do most of the talking and I can be relatively quiet.
Now, that doesn't mean that if a team does not recognize
a performance gap that I'm not going to eventually intervene,
I only intervene only after I've
tried as much as I possibly can to draw that information,
draw that self critique out from them.
Debriefing should be focused on the actions of the individual trainees.
How those actions contributed to the performance of the team.
How team performance influenced patient outcome.
Uh, that is absolutely critical,
we have to get to what happened to the patient,
you know how the actions of the team and actually lead to that.
Uh, in the end what we want is we want the people being debriefed
to develop strategies for replicating those actions that,
uh, result in good care of the patient.
In other words, successful human and system performance,
but also to avoid actions that are ineffective or harmful.
So we again, we really want them to,uh,
be able to reflect and develop these strategies themselves.
And there should always be in any health care debriefing,
uh, a discussion of what happened to the patient.
This is a real key point, uh,
technical performance to briefings which is what Dr. Yamada and I did.
Uh, these are different than critical incident stress debriefings.
These two types of debriefings have different objectives,
and no attempts should ever be made to try to conduct them simultaneously.
And a technical performance debriefing is not therapy.
Technical performance debriefings and
critical incident stress debrie- debriefings are
often confused in health care that's been our experience.
And the way to distinguish these two is at a technical performance debriefing
is focused ultimately on what affected the care of the patient and how the patient did.
Whereas a critical incident stress debriefing is focused on
the emotional health of those who are caring for the patient.
Now, both of those are very important,
both of them have their place,
but it can mean they have very distinct and very different objectives,
and so don't confuse those two when you are debriefing.
Okay. So we'll roll into now our discussion of
these four key strategies that we really wanted to dig into today.
Um, and again, these are just four of 20.
But what we'll- what we'll do for the, um,
next portion of the webinar is actually introduce each strategy followed by
a video clip from a debriefing showing that strategy being implemented by a debriefer.
And then we'll have a little discussion afterwards about really why we feel
that those strategies are important and what we're
hoping to achieve with- with the each- each of those.
Um, just to comment on the clips that you'll see,
these were taken from debriefings that were recorded to illustrate specific points.
Um, so while the actors, uh,
in these debriefings were asked to portray
specific roles for both the scenarios in
which they performed and then the subsequent debriefing.
They're all practicing healthcare professionals, um,
but the debriefer himself was not scripted and really
implemented these strategies as they would be in any debriefing.
The first strategy, again,
is one that I think applies to all debriefings and it's really just how to
prepare learners or people being debriefed to participate in that debriefing.
Um, and we want to show how you can clearly
communicate expectations at the very beginning of a debriefing.
So in this clip [NOISE] it's the first 40 seconds
of the first debriefing with this group of,
uh, people being debriefed and the debriefer who's standing to lead that discussion.
Anyone else's performance outside of the space.
The conversation certainly is open to everyone.
So even if you weren't playing a role in that particular phase of the- the scenario,
please feel free to chime in with any observations,
uh, or thoughts you may have, and be open to learning.
Especially be open to learning from my mistakes, um,
be able to accept any critique both gratefully and gracefully.
And then finally, we have a lot of potential things that we could discuss,
a lot things that we could potentially discuss,
uh, but won't have time to do- go through all those today.
So we'll try to hit the major points.
Okay. So Dr. Halamek,
what are your goals as the debriefer when you
make these types of statements at the beginning of a debriefing?
Well, I think as you could see and hear in that particular video segment,
uh, I have some very specific goals,
things I wanna communicate, uh,
at the beginning of every debriefing,
um, when I'm first meeting this group.
Um, first of all I want to ensure that absolute confidentiality is going
to be maintained, um, during, uh,
any sort of scenario whether it's a simulated scenario or a real scenario,uh,
you may see weaknesses become manifest and certainly those are things
that we want to keep confidential within the group, that's being debriefed.
We want to ensure that there's psychological safety,
meaning that actually people feel safe and comfortable talking about their mistakes,
uh, within the group that's, uh, assembled.
Uh, I would like to see
active participation from all members of the group although I don't mandate it.
I know that some people actually are quiet, uh,
by nature and as long as it appears that they are mentally engaged and are learning,
I don't push people to talk but I certainly would like to see that.
Um, I really want people to be open to learning from mistakes.
If we are running simulated scenarios,
uh, in general those are about making mistakes and learning from those.
So that's a real key expectation that we set up cramped.
Um, and what I talked about at the very end that everyone will accept critique,
and remember critique is not criticism,
but that everyone will accept critique both gratefully and gracefully.
Yeah. And I have to thank, uh,
that my colleague and friend at Johnson Space Center,
Mike Sterling for that because that is sort of the mantra that they
live by when they debrief the astronaut crews and flight controllers.
And then finally, especially if you are working in the real environment, uh,
where you- you don't have a lot of time to debrief after a real event has occurred
with patient care because the teams
have to go back and take care of other patients in that unit.
Um, so for us we were debriefing issues within the ICU or
within labor and delivery then we definitely need to make sure that
people understand we only have a few minutes for this debriefing,
therefore, we're going to cover the most of- what we think are the most important topics,
and then we're going to move on.
Okay. And that's something that you cover to beginning of every debriefing?
Well, it- it depends, uh,
if it's a first time we're meeting a group,
and certainly I'll talk about those things.
I want to make sure that my expectations are clear to them, uh,
and they know that this is going to be an environment in which they
can freely talk about the mistakes and learn from them.
Uh- on the other hand if we're running a training program or
maybe we're running four or five scenarios, uh,
over the course of the morning or the day, uh,
then I won't repeat those every time,
as long as I'm sure that people under- understood them, heard them the first time.
Okay. [NOISE]. All right.
And so then moving into actually initiating the debriefing itself.
Um, one of the things that we always talk about,
and when we talk about how to really
run an effective debriefing is starting with this question.
What happened in 10 words or less?
And so this next clip will show this first question being asked by the debriefer.
And then the initial responses given by the people being debriefed.
To start off, uh, what happened in that scenario in 10 words or less?
Term neonate, umbilical cord rupture, needed blood.
Okay.
I would say term neonate,
um, hypoxic, hypovolemic, for resuscitation.
Okay. Anyone else?
Any other additional input?
I think that included everything.
Okay.
Many debriefers in health care had been taught to or
even prefer to start their debriefings with a question along the lines of,
how did that go, how did that feel?
Um, and the question here asked was,
what happened to in 10 minutes or less,
why do you start debriefing that one? [NOISE]
Um, well, the- that particular question, um, you know,
how did that go, uh,
for those of us who use video,
um, it- it's oftentimes it's hard to,
to know exactly how that went.
Uh-huh.
What happened before you've watched the video and have
a chance to actually assess performance.
So we try to avoid, uh,
if we're going to be using video,
whether it's a real-life scenario that we're playing video back, uh,
for or it's a simulated scenario,
we try to avoid getting into the debriefing too
much with an assessment just based solely on memory.
We got to watch the video and critique it in real time.
So we avoid that question.
We also avoid the question is in terms of how did you feel about that.
Um, I know that's very commonly used and people are free to
choose however they would like to start their debriefing,
but, um, I've not heard that question
asked [NOISE] in other high-risk industries that do debriefing.
Um, I think that it can set the debriefing up to be confused with the,
uh, critical incident stress debriefing,
which again as we've talked about earlier,
a critical incident stress debriefings and
technical performance debriefings are two very different things,
and what we're really talking about here today are technical performance debriefings.
And so I try to avoid those kinds of questions
because they can be rather subjective and at times rather vague.
So by saying what happened in 10 words or less,
we try to accomplish a couple of very important things.
First of all, um,
we- we try really hard to set a professional business,
as a matter of fact, tone for the debriefing.
Um, we want people to know that, you know, again,
saving lives is our business,
that tone is extremely important,
uh, for the debriefing.
And we don't want to waste anybody's time, uh,
with superfluous conversation, especially if we have
very limited time to cover important topics in patient care.
And so that's the first thing that it does.
The second thing that it does is it does encourage people to
be concise and precise in our use of language,
uh, and as we discuss the, uh,
I've mentioned several times now,
that especially when debriefing in the real environment where time pressure's quite
intense and we have after we taking care of one patient and we debrief that,
we have other patients that are waiting for our care.
Right.
So we don't have the luxury of,
of lots and lots of time for- the degree for real situation.
Now, we may have that luxury if we're debriefing
simulated situations in a training program,
but even there, we don't want to waste time.
Uh, on my experience over the last two-plus decades in using
simulation healthcare is that what teams really
want is they want to get in these many scenarios as they possibly can.
So if we are being redundant in our new briefing,
if at least they're perceiving that perhaps
we're not covering any new material during the debriefing,
we're discussing things aren't terribly important, uh,
then they start to get antsy and they would much prefer to, uh,
be in another scenario and see what more they can learn rather
than continuing to talk about things that perhaps aren't as relevant as it should be.
Okay. Uh, but what happened,
in 10 words or less, is a very specific question too.
Um, sometimes, uh, another strategy that I've seen debrief previews is asking
the questions what went well and what didn't go
well in that scenario and starting out a debriefing that way.
Can you comment on how that strategy compares to using what happened in 10 words or less?
Again, a lot of these things are personal preference.
Uh-huh.
Um, [NOISE] uh, sometimes in the real environment
when- when time pressure is intense, uh,
I'll see people say, well, what went well,
they typically start with what went well then they get to what- what didn't go so well.
Um, the only issue about that is that, um, uh,
for example, let's say we determine that you and I
are working on a patient and something did not go well.
Uh-huh.
We say, "Okay, uh, the intubation of that patient did not go well."
Uh, if we don't then drill down,
if we don't get to the underlying causes of why that intubation [NOISE] did not go well,
you know, it can be something like a deficit in content knowledge.
Uh, we didn't know what size of endotracheal tube used.
We didn't know how to properly handle the endoscope.
It could be a problem with decision-making.
Uh, we didn't, um, make the right decision.
We decided to intubate too soon or we decided to intubate too late.
It could be that are- the actual technical skill, hand-eye coordination,
the way they- we handle the endoscope and
the endotracheal tube wasn't appropriate and didn't allow us to be successful,
or could involve a host of behavioral skills around communication.
Maybe we didn't effectively ask for the right size of equipment.
Uh, maybe the ambient noise of the room is
too high and we weren't able to hear one another.
All of those kinds of things and all of those skill sets can actually
influence why something did not go well or why it went very well,
Right.
And those into being
the critically important aspects of what
happened that you want to cover during any briefing.
So if you just stay at a very superficial level of, you know,
tell me three things that went well and three things that didn't go well,
again, if you have very limited time,
you have only a few minutes to carry a debriefing,
that gets people thinking about
those particular aspects but it doesn't drill down to the underlying root causes.
And that's, uh, something that you really need to
be able to get you at some point, uh, during the debriefing.
Okay. So your hope with the- what happened,
in 10 minutes or less, is just the beginning,
and then really the rest of the debriefing is to discuss
a lot of those other issues more in specific terms?
Tha- that's correct, yes.
Okay. So moving on to the next strategy.
This is titled Avoiding Qualitative Statements and it really describes, um,
our goal of trying to draw
performance assessment from the learners or from the people being debriefed.
And then just to give the audience some background on the clip that's being used here,
this is taken from a debriefing of the care of a premature infant,
who is in respiratory failure and in need of CPR.
I mean, at this point, the group is discussing the team's, uh,
decision of whether to intubate the patient
prior to the initiation of start of chest compressions.
And we will see that the trainees or the people being
debriefed address a question directly to the debriefer,
and what I want to point your attention to is how the debriefer
responds and the discussion that follows from the trainees.
What do you think? Is it difficult to intubate while someone's doing compression?
Have you ever done that?
Let's- let's see if we have any consensus among the group.
So the choices are to not do compressions in intubating,
focus on the intubation.
Because it was mentioned that sometimes it can be difficult to
intubate while the chest is moving especially in a very small patient.
Um, another choice is to start compressions and hold off on intubation,
perhaps do bag mask.
The other choice is to do both simultaneously.
Do we have any consensus among
this team about what should be done right now with a heart rate of 26,
four minutes, roughly a little over four minutes in- of age?
I think if the intubator is comfortable,
it should start with chest compressions and intubation at the same time.
Okay.
But if it's starting to interfere,
then you should hold off on the chest compressions
because the intubation is most important and only takes a brief moment,
Good.
And it does take a while for you to build up,
um, enough blood flow to have appropriate cerebral perfusion pressure.
Good. Okay. So backup team comes into
the room and the backup physician is immediately given an order to intubate.
Please watch what happens from this point. And.
Okay. Uh, so in this clip,
we demonstrated this concept of avoiding qualitative statements. What does that mean?
[NOISE] Concretely, it means to avoid use of adjectives and adverbs.
And the way if you are leading the debriefing
and the way you're speaking with the team in,
in avoiding- providing any sort of qualitative assessment of their performance.
You know, we've talked about several times already
in the course of our discussion here today that
it's really important for members of these teams to be able to look at their performance,
reflect on their performance,
and come up with their own assessment.
[NOISE] Uh, it's not going to be possible to have
a trained degree for available to run through the hospital
24 hours a day to be present for every debriefing that should be taking
place [NOISE] and so we need our teams to be able to do this.
Um, um, I think it's a professionalism issue.
I think it's, uh, issue of- quite honestly,
delivering optimal patient care.
So they have to be able to reflect on their own performance,
um, and decide whether their performance was optimal or not.
If it wasn't optimal, okay, what are the weaknesses?
Let's identify those weaknesses and let's begin to discuss strategies
for making sure those weaknesses don't become manifest in the future.
Um, similarly, if it was- if the team performed at a very high level, yeah,
if their performance was deemed to be optimal under the circumstances, uh,
they really need to understand what it was,
what it was that enabled them to perform at such a high level.
Because it's- it's one thing to do a really good job at something,
it's another thing to understand how to replicate that good job in the future.
Uh-huh.
And so it's not just about weaknesses,
it's not just about good performance,
it's actually about understanding the underlying, uh, uh,
causes or the, um, uh,
abilities that, uh, the circumstances that actually allow teams to perform,
uh, along that, uh, performance spectrum.
Uh-huh. [NOISE] But in this situation, um,
one of the people that being debriefed actually asked you a question directly, um,
and you're an experienced neonatologists
with expertise in neonatal resuscitation and you probably have
an opinion in this case whether or not the team
did the correct thing or the best thing for this patient,
um, but instead, you've responded with let's see
if we have many consensus from the group.
Why did you avoid answering that question?
Well, I- I could have easily answered that question.
Uh-huh.
Um, and the- that team was turning to me as,
uh, the person that answered the question and tell them how they did.
Uh-huh.
Um, I don't see that as the role of the debriefer.
Again, unless there is a problem
that- that they are unable to recognize with their performance,
where you might need to step in and help them recognize that.
Uh-huh.
Um, uh, you really want to draw that answer out from them.
You want them to, uh,
assess their own performance as best they possibly can. Um.
We typically debrief experience health care professionals that the team that- well,
we seen in that video was, uh, obviously,
a team of experienced health care professionals.
More than likely there's
at least one if not more people in the room who know the answer to that question already.
We say they have their own answer formulated.
And what can happen is if I tell them immediately what I think should have been done,
I potentially can shut down discussion because they're gonna say, "Oh,
the debriefer or Doctor Halamek just said this is what should be done.
I was thinking maybe something different should be done,
but if that's what he says,
then that's what we should go with."
Uh-huh.
And I don't wanna make the supposition that since I
wasn't in the scenario that I know exactly what it is they were seeing,
what it is they were hearing,
and go ahead and tell them what should have been done.
Uh-huh.
Because they may have been an alternative strategy that's just as
effective or perhaps even more effective than what I might be talking about.
And so I never wanna shut down that kind of discussion,
I wanna give it a time to,
to come up to the surface, uh,
because oftentimes, the people that are being debriefed have they come up with
some very unique and very valuable solutions to these [NOISE] kinds of
problems and I'd rather hear from them first.
Uh, again, that doesn't mean that if at the end of,
uh, a discussion and, uh,
after multiple attempts to try to draw what I feel would
be the best answer out from them if they fail to recognize especially a witness,
uh, then we do need to intervene,
we do need to call attention to that and tell them the right thing to do.
You don't want them to leave that space thinking that, you know,
knowing that or you know that they did something that potentially could harm the patient.
Right.
You don't want them leaving that space thinking that, uh,
uh, that was the right thing to do because that will lead to, uh, patient harm.
Uh-huh.
So you can't let that happen.
But in general, especially with experienced health care professionals,
there's someone who can draw the answer from it.
It's much more powerful that comes from them rather than comes to them.
Yeah. So we're talking a lot about drawing
assessment of performance from the people being debriefed,
but the other thing that this, uh,
strategy was related to was avoiding qualitative statements.
Can you give us an example of what that really means?
Um, sure. This- this is one I use all the time whenever I talk about this.
Um, [NOISE] if I have two teams, uh,
with me and team one is coming out from
the scenario for debriefing and I look at them and I say at some point during that debriefing,
yes, I'm conversing with them,
"Oh, you guys did a great job."
And then team two comes out and they come up for
their debriefing and somewhere in that conversation I say,
"Oh, you guys did a good job."
What ends up happening is even though both teams performed at an adequate level,
the team that heard the word great now is thinking that their performance was much,
much better than the team that heard that word good.
And so those are two perfectly acceptable adjectives.
They both indicate, you know, good performance, uh,
adequate performance, yet I set-up a
dynamic here where that I probably didn't wanna set up.
There's- there's enough, uh,
difficulty sometimes in debriefing especially with different groups of people,
uh, that they're reading a lot into it anyway,
so my preferences to not add to that.
Uh, not make it more difficult for them to discern,
uh, I don't want them to just try to discern for me,
what their performance is like,
uh, but I'd rather have it come from them, uh,
and, and bubble up for them because,
again, they're gonna remember it much better.
Um, and, uh, I think be able
to translate whatever it is we talked about into their practice,
uh, if it comes from them,
rather than sort of in the grade school teacher type,
teacher-student type of role where I'm the source of all knowledge,
they don't know much of anything,
every time that they have a question,
they asked me, I answer.
Um, again, with health care professionals, who are adults,
who are intelligent people,
experienced people, most of the time they know the answers already.
Yeah, yeah. And I can imagine how that also helps to, uh,
[NOISE] and I've seen how that helps to avoid
creating defensiveness in debriefings too because you're really
asking for their own assessment of
their performance and they're not looking to the debriefer for,
um, some validation or some feedback.
Um, the next strategy also talks more about
de- defensiveness and really how to deconstruct
defensiveness and try to minimize
defensiveness and that's limiting the use of second person pronouns.
So in this clip, um,
this is a debriefing separate from the- the one that we just watched.
Uh, this is the resuscitation of a full-term infant,
who was in cardiac arrest, um,
and the team in this scenario struggled to provide timely care.
And so by this point in the debriefing, um,
it's already been established that several steps of
the resuscitation were delayed relative to the standard of care.
And so because of that, multiple members of the team are unhappy with their performance.
So let's watch this clip to see how the debriefer- [NOISE] debriefer handles this,
um, challenging situations.
[NOISE]
So in terms of the ergonomics at the bedside,
the crowding at the bedside,
is there anything that can be done about that?
Anything that could have been done about that?
Well, the patient could had been bagged from this side that I'm on now.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
So that would have freed up space.
Okay. And what could have led to that not happening in this scenario?
[NOISE] I think not just not being aware that,
um, [NOISE] there wasn't enough room for her [NOISE] to really get in there and see,
Uh-huh.
Okay. What the- what led to that lack of awareness? [NOISE]
I guess, I mean not saying anything.
Okay. And what prevent- what could prevent
an individual in a situation
like this from speaking up about they don't have enough room?
[NOISE]
If so focused on that task.
Okay. [NOISE]
I think it's hard to do.
It's hard for me to speak up sometimes when [OVERLAPPING]
Why is it hard?
Because I don't wanna let the team down or I don't want people to think that I can't do
something when I can do it but the circumstances aren't exactly right,
and sometimes that's just really hard for me to verbalize.
[NOISE] But the most important person is the patient
and they're the ones that really need at the line. So,
That's true.
I feel like we have to find a way to get over that and took it over,
you know, and to be okay with switching roles and saying I can't get this done right now.
Anything else that any other member of this team could have done to determine that
the int- intravascular access was not yet secured?
I think the team leader could've checked in.
Okay.
Earlier.
Team leader could have acquired about that?
Uh-huh.
Okay. Anybody else on the team could have acquired about that, right?
I think I definitely could have because when you're doing ventilations and compressions,
it's hard to do anything else.
Okay.
But I wasn't doing either.
So I could have checked and saw what the status of the fluids and the line placement was.
There's a number of things that could have been done
differently to perhaps avoid that situation.
[NOISE] Okay.
So one of the things I noticed in that clip is that you can even tell from the-
the body language of some of the people being debriefed
that they were really unhappy and really defensive.
And in general, debriefing professionals,
practicing healthcare professionals or people
even outside of health care who might be experts in their field and
have experienced a difficult situation or
one in which they made mistakes can be really challenging.
Um, people can often be
defensive in those envi- in those situations when they're talking about
their performance and they're examining their performance and even in this type of
situation where you might have video of what they've done,
um, to- to show them back.
Um, so how do you approach those types of situations?
Well, I think the reason you're concerned about
defensiveness is because defensiveness can impair learning.
And the debriefing is all about learning again.
Learning strengths, learning [NOISE] weaknesses,
how to replicate the good things and avoid the bad things in the future.
Uh, but it's also important to remember what we talked about very early on,
which was that a technical performance debriefing
is not a critical like incident stress debriefing.
Uh-huh.
Um, when I've seen debriefings take place in either high-risk industries,
the debriefings really are not about, um, uh,
making people feel better,
they're about making people be [NOISE] better,
upping the performer at a higher level.
And so in an instance like that where the team did [NOISE] not perform,
at least in that phase of the patient care,
the team did not perform an optimal level,
it doesn't surprise me that they are unhappy.
In fact, I would expect that they would be unhappy,
and [NOISE] I would be much more concerned if they were happy with poor performance.
Uh-huh.
That tells me that we've got
some actually significant issues that neither the seriousness with
which they're taking their participation in
that particular scenario or they just don't understand,
uh, in general, how important it is to, uh,
be able to uncover the root causes of the weaknesses that become manifest.
Um, one of the things we did see in that clip is that, um, uh,
going back to some of our prior discussion,
uh, the team [NOISE] did not stay at a very superficial level.
Uh-huh.
Okay, yes, the line did not go in in a timely manner.
Uh, what we were able to do the course that
debriefing it does actually drill down to the underlying root causes,
and there were actually [NOISE] a number of those that were,
uh, uh, elicited from the people being debriefed.
So, um, that's really what you wanna be able to get out into the debriefing.
Um, personally, I think that if you
maintain a professional business-like matter-of-fact approach from your debriefing,
again, you are not really excited and happy with the team performance, well,
you're not really sort of down and depressed when the team's not performing well.
And they're not reading your either,
they're not hear- they're using your words or using
your nonverbal communication to assess
their performance but rather they're thinking through it critically,
uh, and then you allow- you lead them through a discussion that allows them to
uncover the underlying root causes and come up with strategies to overcome those,
I think that's where we get to the point where actually
we're going to have teams that are again performing,
uh, enough, or executing in a flawless manner.
It doesn't mean that they're perfect,
but it means that when things don't go well,
they're able to, uh,
uh, enable contingency plans.
Uh-huh.
Um, and enact those and falsely execute those.
Uh-huh. Okay. And in this clip,
getting back to this particular strategy,
you really avoided, um,
in a specific, it seemed very intentional, um,
using the second person pronouns like you, or you guys,
or even addressing, uh,
any of the people in that debriefing by name.
Can you tell us how that strategy helps to minimize defensiveness during a debriefing?
Sure. I think we need to avoid the use of the- the second person pronoun you,
uh, the people being debriefed can be much more objective about their performance.
Um, either way, they're talking about themselves or talking about, uh, their colleagues.
Um, because you're not putting them on the spot.
You're talking about, uh,
the physician in that particular, uh, you've got,
for example, rather than Doctor Yamada or Nicole.
And I've seen that repeatedly and that's actually something we brought in
from- we brought in from watching military debriefings.
Uh-huh.
Um, it's especially important when performance of sub-optimal.
Now sometimes groups themselves will use second person pronouns,
pronouns, that's fine if they're comfortable with that.
But as the debriefer I try to avoid that as much as possible.
Um, for example, I would never ask them
individual in a debriefing, "Why didn't you do that?"
That really puts them on the spot.
If they're not defensive already they're going to become defensive.
Instead I would ask the team, you know,
if it's- if it's about the physician, for example,
I'd say, what did the physician needing a resuscitation just do.
And once we do that and I'm
referring to the- the physician in the third person rather than by name,
actually it makes it much easier for that physician to talk about
his or her personal actions and whether they were good or bad for the patient.
Um, it also enables the people- other people being debriefed who
may not usually be in a position where they're often
critique to a position or to someone who's more senior than they are.
And they can talk about that physician in the third person and it makes it
easier for them to offer their own observations about that individual's performance.
So, um, the- the key is to try to encourage discussion,
encourage self-reflection, uh, avoid
defensiveness because that tends to inhibit those things.
Um, but then follow it up with a series of questions
where you actually begin to drill down to the root causes.
So as- as you've said several times now in the course, this webinar.
The overall goal is to be able to train these teams so they can debrief themselves.
Uh, whether it be debriefing simulated events.
Uh, because ultimately that's what's going to
allow all of us collectively to enhance our performance.
So we've talked a lot about these strategies in the context of taking
care of patients or even in the context of running simulations.
Can you, um, comment a little bit about how you see these types of strategies and
the things that we've- that we do talk about in
our online course being translated even outside of healthcare.
Sure. I think the ability to objectively, uh, self-reflect,
and critique one's own performance as well as to objectively and, uh,
in a non-punitive way talk about college performance,
is what allows individuals and teams to overall perform at a high level.
I've certainly seen that in industries outside of health care, uh,
where either the lives of other individuals
or the lives of the debriefees themselves are at stake.
But I've even seen it in things like, uh,
or in activities such as athletics.
Um, where the best athletes tend to be the one to
instead of falling apart or not recognizing, uh,
what their only misses are they're able to objectively assess those weaknesses,
and then develop strategies perhaps in concert with
a coach but develop strategies to overcome those weaknesses.
Um, those are the athletes who can handle failure.
This failure always comes to an athlete at some point,
and they're the ones who are able to go beyond that in actually excel at what they do.
Okay. All right.
I think with that we'll turn it back over, um, to Jackie.
Okay. So our first question is how can
these techniques be applied to scenarios outside of emergency care,
for example, chronic inpatient care or even outside of health care?
Um, in terms of outside of
health care I think one of
the best examples I can give actually involved very junior people.
Um, I'm the faculty athletic fellow is sort of a liaison between women's, uh,
indoor volleyball team here at Stanford in the- the faculty,
and their coaching staff uses these strategies extremely well.
Um, think of a coach as someone who's always telling somebody what to do.
Uh, well, what I have seen Coach Hambly do and his staff do exceedingly well is,
rather than always be telling the players what they
shouldn't be doing or what they shouldn't be doing,
um, in the huddle it before the game, before the match,
during the match, after the match, he'll ask them, uh,
for their assessment of their own performance,
and what if anything they needed you differently.
And these are 18-22 year old young women who are very good at doing this.
So they just won a national championship last year in fact.
Um, so when I see that kind of ability to self-reflect,
analyze and come up with strategies
to perform at a higher level in- in each group like that,
I think that certainly that's something that all of us,
uh, throughout our lives should be able to do.
Um, other high-risk industries do this quite
well effectively they do much better than we do in health care,
quite on soon they've been doing it for a long time,
NASA has been doing this for 50 years or 60 years.
So in any sort of environment where individual and team performance is important.
Uh, the ability of the individuals to self-reflect and the ability of
the team to reflect to put
those self-reflections together to come up with an assessment of team performance.
And again, look at what did we do well?
How can we replicate those things in the future?
And what did we not do very well?
What weaknesses became manifest?
And what strategies can we collectively come
up with so that we can avoid those things in the future?
Um, It really applies across the board.
Okay. Um, our next question is, uh,
the presenters indicated that working from
a recording is far preferable to going from memory.
And If they don't record the actual in the moment
resuscitations to review on at a later date,
do you have any suggestions?
Yeah. That's a common challenge that we hear
about from people who are running debriefings.
Um, and I think you know,
as- as we tried to show in these,
um, debriefings, it is ideal to have that objective record, uh,
to reference too so that everybody can see both the- end of
the entire group of people being debriefed as well as
the debriefer can really see that performance,
um, and share that understanding before really discussing that performance.
Um, but oftentimes that may not be available for whatever reason
whether it's time or technology, um, capabilities.
And so I think just at least having some type of an objective record
of what happened is the- is the goal of what you might want to start with.
So even if it's not recorded,
perhaps it's written you can take, uh, you know,
in a- in an emergency situation oftentimes people are
recording the- on the code sheet the events that happen,
or if it's not an emergency situation, if it's,
um, another health care situation or again,
even outside of healthcare,
just a record of what the series of events were and use that
as the shared understanding of the team of really what actually happened.
And then the goal of the debriefing is to dig down
into why does events happened as they did?
And what the team might have been able to do differently.
Um, or again, if it was a good performance but
the team really did well in that situation and to try to replicate that.
And I think that's really important for folks to understand that if
there is no objective record of individual and team performance,
and if you are trying to reflect on your own performance
as you were involved in that particular event, um,
one- especially if it's- if you're trying to perform under intense time pressure,
your ability to remember things while you are-
you have perhaps a life at stake or some other serious issue,
and you're doing things actively.
It's often very difficult,
your memory may be impaired in terms of
remembering exactly what you did and when you did it, how you did it.
Ah, Another thing that can happen is you
can- if you are part of that you can lose objectivity.
And so you may be either hypercritical
or excessively critical of something that you did or your colleagues did.
Um, or you may not be critical enough and
you may think that you did a much better job than you actually did.
So, uh, we encourage people especially if you are- if- if
we're- if- if- if it's possible to get video it's really important to do that,
um, and use that because when you're debriefing it really
resolves a lot of questions about who did what when?
Who said what when? How do they do that?
Uh, it gives everybody, uh, a very objective,
very concrete basis upon which to offer critique.
Thank you. Um, we've had a few questions about,
um, the timing of debriefing,
so do you have any guidelines or suggestions for
a longer-term retrospective debrief so outside of an immediate setting two weeks,
to a month or more?
And also is there an extension of time,
um, that is considered appropriate for a debriefing?
So if we're- if we're debriefing real life events, um,
in general you'd like to debrief those as close to the event as possible.
Um, now you do have to sort some things out,
I talked about the critical incident stress debriefing.
Uh, if it's a particularly traumatic event like for us in our field,
it could be the death of the patient.
Um, there are some folks who are ready
to debrief that right away because their whole focus is on,
what can we do differently to perhaps avoid that are coming in the future,
and there are other folks who from
an emotional standpoint are not ready to do that at that time.
And so they may need a critical incident stress debriefing
before they actually can participate effectively in the debriefing.
But in general, I think that's- that's smaller number of people.
Um, so ideally when memories are fresh, get everyone together.
Uh, debrief on that again.
Um, sometimes it's not possible to spend much time doing that, and so,
uh, when it isn't possible,
try to cover perhaps the most important one or two points.
And again, not just very superficially,
but try to drill down a bit on those and the underlying root causes,
keep- ask people to create a list of other things that occurred in the scheduling events,
uh, where you actually can bring people together in the future,
uh, and to go over things in more detail.
Uh, but again objective records are very helpful,
um, and the ability to- at least, uh,
if you're going to delay the briefing to at least
cover one or two very important aspects of that,
I think can become critical and maintaining
people's interest in helping them to, you know.
Hopefully if- if there are weaknesses,
avoid those because the same thing could happen in the next hour, the next day.
Um, and if- if there are particular strengths have become manifest,
you wanna be able to help them replicate those,
uh, and you need a teacher also.
Okay. And then long the same lines,
ideally how often should you debrief?
After every event?
After each new patient?
How often do you debrief?
I think in a perfect world we are debriefing, you know, all the time.
Um, but I think because debriefing does take people away from care,
it can be challenging.
So the, um, clearly the- the times then
we debriefed the most often at least in health care is after a mistake is made,
um, or after a critical event in which a patient,
um, patient status may have changed acutely.
Um, but really I would see debriefing and even the strategies that we use in
debriefings aren't limited to only those discussions that we title as debriefings,
I think a lot of these strategies can apply
to just having conversations with one another,
about trying to uncover, um,
how we as a team could continue to perform well or- or improve our performance.
So for example, something like, um,
avoiding qualitative statements and- and try to minimize defensiveness.
Sometimes when I'm talking to my colleagues,
even in very short discussions about
something that I did or something that we did as a team,
I employ those strategies with the goal of really just trying to learn how to do better.
Um, but I think as a starting point to that specific questions specifically,
um, I think, you know, after, uh,
an acute event when a patient status
change- changes is really the- the clear starting point,
but then learning how to disseminate
these strategies in discussions beyond that is really our goal.
Remember very important point is especially for
those of you who are listening in our health care.
Um, when you debrief for real life health care event, um,
you want to first have some sort of policy or procedure in place as to how to do that.
And I would recommend that you talk to
the risk managers at your hospital, or your clinic,
or your school, uh,
to go- to know how to go about that.
And that's not to say that we want to practice
defensive medicine and cover up our weaknesses fighting means.
Uh, if we determine that a weakness has become
manifested and as resulted in
patient harm and of course we're going to talk to that patient,
we're going to talk to that patient's family about the significance of that.
But what we want to be able to do during
any briefing is we want people to be able to speak freely.
And if they feel that they are perhaps,
uh, placing themselves at, uh,
legal risk or their institution at legal risk,
they may not speak freely and we may never uncover the root cause of a particular issue.
And so it's really to protect the confidentiality of that group,
get as much information,
accurate information as possible out into that discussion,
come up with what the root causes are for that event,
and then develop solutions around those.
And then of course once that's determined if- if we need to inform the patient,
the patient's family that perhaps,
yes we were in error,
uh, then we need to go ahead and do that.
So again, talk to your legal team, uh,
It's not about practicing defensive medicine,
it's actually by getting the best information
out and then doing the right thing for the patient.
Okay. Our next question here is in a debrief setting,
how would you approach a person who routinely
cannot admit to or see that they'd made a mistake?
And how would you deal with colleagues who refuse
formal or critical stress debriefing in a less formal,
but more helpful way for them?
I think those are two separate questions.
[LAUGHTER]. Um, so the first one,
ah, is regarded- is regarding just common challenges.
Um, people who can't see their own weaknesses or perhaps refuse to see
their own weaknesses or acknowledged them or clearly don't wanna talk
about them and kind of just lumping them all in that defensive category.
Um, I think that situation is really
a place where having an objective record can be very very valuable.
And that's why especially,
um, in training, uh,
circumstances when- when the environment allows or, you know,
if there's an ability to setup video,
that video is your best friend as the debriefer in that situation
because now you have a record where you don't have to get
in a situation where the debriefers were counting what happened if perhaps
that defensive person is arguing with what actually happened or what they said or did.
Um, you can really just refer to the video,
and let everybody that you briefing see that,
and then just talk about it in a very objective manner.
You now what happened, um,
the series of events,
what were the circumstances that led to those different series of events.
But then, also, um,
being careful i think to avoid perhaps directing
all of the questions specifically to that person,
even though you as a debriefer may think that that person
had the primary responsibility for that series of events.
Um, but asking the group as a whole to
analyze the team's performance in that situation, um,
and then using strategies like we cover here where you're avoiding the second person,
you're really inviting everybody to discuss, um, their perceptions,
um, and their understanding of how the team performed in that particular situation.
That's a common concern that people won't want to talk about their errors,
will be really defensive.
Uh, again, we've used video for a long time.
I've been debriefing for over two decades now,
and my experience with that is actually that's a fairly rare occurrence.
Um, because the video,
you really can't argue with it, it's there.
And the vast majority of the time,
even when people perform poorly, uh,
they're more than willing to talk about it because it's there,
everybody sees it, and they want to find a way to avoid that in the future.
So I haven't seen that to be a common problem at all,
even though it gets talked about quite a bit within the health care debriefing community.
I'm sorry, there was a second part to the question also.
[LAUGHTER]. Um, yeah.
So how would you debrief colleagues who refuse
formal critical stress debriefing in a less formal but still helpful way?
Yeah. I think that those kinds of things- some- sometimes on
a rare occasion that may actually occur during a debriefing itself,
with it just becomes manifests as somebody's having
a really difficult time and really can't participate.
And so- our strategies are to actually,
um, send the rest of your thought for a quick break,
and then talk to that person one-on-one,
asking if there's somebody- that they can call,
you can call to help them out,
um, ask them if they can continue.
Uh, you can't force anyone, uh,
to go see someone, uh,
even though you think they need help,
but what you can do is you can be compassionate in your approach,
recognize when they might need help and offer that to them.
Okay. Thank you.
All right.
Well, unfortunately we're getting close to the hour,
so we'll have to wrap up the Q&A session.
Thank you very much Dr. Halamek and Dr.
Yamada for sharing your knowledge with our participants today.
And for those of you who have indicated an interest in the program,
our team will be reaching out with more information and you can always
visit us the scpd.stanford.edu/debriefing.
As a final reminder, the recording of this webinar will be emailed to you within a week,
and thank you all for joining us today.
Have a great rest of your week.